as experts begin to search for other
explanations
they turn their attention to a series of
disturbing discoveries
that occurred in the months following
the june 2012 attacks
we have some dolphins that washed up
already dead
[Music]
we weren't really sure what it was but
we did hear from other states that they
were having the same issue
in fact it turns out that over the
course of 2013
a total of 48 dolphins are found dead
on south carolina beaches
researchers concluded the dolphins were
inflicted with the morbilia virus
this deadly disease suppresses the
dolphins immune system
and causes inflammation of the brain the
result is a bizarre shift in behavior
infected dolphins have been witnessed
swimming in strange patterns
almost like they are drunk and
additional research has shown that brain
inflammation in zebrafish caused them to
become
more agitated
so in 2012 could the sharks of myrtle
beach have been inflicted with a disease
that changed their behavior making them
more likely to bite swimmers
according to dr dan huber it comes down
to a shark's immune system
for animals the skin is the first line
of defense against any type of an
infection so the skin is
part of the immune system essentially
looking at a section of shark skin which
shows what are called dermal denticles
which are basically little teeth that
make up the scales of a shark
the denticles perform a unique function
in the shark's immune system
dermal denticles creates a very uneven
shape that bacteria have a hard time
adhering to because the bacteria can't
adhere to it they can't form colonies
and this is something that helps sharks
to resist bacterial infections
and there's also another organ that
helps protect
sharks from disease
their liver the liver produces a
chemical compound called squalamine
the squalamine is dispersed inside the
shark
cells if a virus invades the cells
the squalamine prevents it from
multiplying
so the virus doesn't spread and the
shark
doesn't get sick scientists are even
testing squalamine
to fight cancer in humans
this remarkable immune system means that
sharks might be one of the most
disease-resistant creatures
on earth any suggestion that the sharks
could have become ill due to a virus or
a bacterial infection
isn't very likely because sharks have
very strong immune systems
[Music]
you